[Musique]
à
la famille doit est en pis tu me salis
attente on doit venir
oui un essaim du credo abeilles
attention c'est dangereux non au four
en attendant on essaye de faire tomber
les saints d'abel cachés par des
feuilles c'est imprudent tentons vois je
te l'avais dit un petit bisou au
deuxième petite piste déjà privés de
leurs essaims les crédos au bypass à
l'attack attention
[Musique]
partagera sort une bombe à 5 et 6
les taudis à tous apportent des fleurs
pour les crédos abeilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour regarder comme est content
[Musique]
ce qu'ils voient tous les toits
oh
un peu de fumée pour endormir les crédos
baber on récupère le miel ne reste plus
martinez
et déguster au
à travailler crédit aux abeilles merci à
tous au revoir
où
et